مع الان مباشره من بغداد مراسل فرانس
فانكاتخ ابراهيم صالح ابراهيم اهلا ومرحبا
بك معنا ابراهيم ما هي اخر التفاصيل
المتوفره لديك حول هذا الانفجار
الحرس الثوري الايراني عمليات القصف او
بلحره هي ثلاثه عمليات قصف استهدفت ثلاث
مطار للحزب الديمقراطيه الكردستاني
الايراني
داخل اقليم كردستان
ثالث
سليمانيه ويبدا انها كانت عمليات
او محاوله
لعدد من قاده هذا الحزب على اعتبار ان همم
الوحيد في هذه العمل
والقياده في همم الحزب الديمقراطيه لكل
الثانيه الايراني
هتقول الاصابات في هذه العمليه التي
تمناها طبعا الحارس الفوري همم الايراني
وفقا لمواقع ومصادر ايرانيه مقربه من
الحرس الثوري رشيده اشكرك ابراهيم كنت
معنا مباشره من العاصمه العراقيه بغداد